hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comma today we're going to
be looking at the Tennyson game it
starts out with Pawnee for pond e5
Knight f3 so they take this pawn if you
want to or if you really wanted to try
starting out with Knight f3 same moves
get there a few different ways pond d5
and then pawn to e4 after pawn takes on
e4 we're only going to be looking at the
accepted lines it happens almost all the
time Knight to g5 but I'm gonna get
tricky and play 9th adji 1 or try
anything else Knight here to g5 in this
video we're going to look at the main
lines that black may play against this
one you might see as pawn to e5 and this
pretty much says I'm going to give that
material right back I don't know what
the hey you're doing with this opening
but I'm not falling for any traps so go
ahead and take that pawn back I'm going
to develop my pieces like I normally
would that suggests what you're going to
do you're going to take here on e4 and
they could try a couple things the first
thing is to add pressure on this pawn or
this night right here on e4 with pawn to
f5 you're going to bring your knight
here to g3 don't bring it over here to
c3 and you bring it back here to g3
because you're kind of hoping that they
continue to extend a little bit further
than they should with pawn to f4 and
players that are not familiar with the
Tennyson gambit such as we on black side
you'll see this often because it doesn't
seem too crazy but you can already sense
that the Kings side the board is just
too open she could play Queen to h5
check pawn to g6 check Queen's gonna
have to come here to e7 we see an
exchange on board after the Knight takes
Knight here to e4 and then all of a
sudden whites up a material and has a
much better position can easily give his
life to her Bishop involved into the
game castle on the King side much better
setup on board than black cast now if we
come back and say instead of pawn to f4
which i think is definitely a mistake
you could play Knight to f6 ok let's get
a little bit more aggressive Bishop here
to c4 we could see nice e6 pawn d3
gettering get our dark square Bishop
involved into the game so this is all
you know pretty solid
even if you wanted to get his queen
involvement of the game start to attack
this pawn here on at five Cs is nice any
potentially could have his queen there
so have some options but that's how you
would approach it if he instead decides
to play Knight to c6 I would still do
the same thing Bishop here to c4
continually putting pressure on the
square here on f7 and then that's
prepping same thing pawn d3 castle on
the King side so you have lots of
options now if he doesn't want to add
pressure with pawn to f5 you could play
Knight to f6 and then you can play
Bishop to b5 check they could play a
knight c6 you could take here after they
capture you could go ahead and take
after the Queen takes you castle on the
King side and I think this is completely
fun you're even in material here because
they gave that pawn back to you and all
in all this is a pretty good structure
they have double pawns here on the C
file they don't have pawns connected to
it so it's when you get into the endgame
white should definitely have a good game
here and if they don't decide to bring
their knight to c6 they could try to
block it with pawn to c6 I would go
ahead and just take tonight here after
the Queen takes you bring your Bishop
back here to see for putting pressure on
this f7 squared and you can cast on the
King side get your queen involved if you
wanted to so lots of different options
that's kind of what happens if they play
that just pawn to e5 which says not
really sure exactly what's going on go
ahead and take that material back if you
want to the next option you may see is
pawn to f5 this I think is one of the
worst ways to respond but sometimes they
try to protect that material any way
possible and a lot of times they try to
defend that with pawn so pawn to f5 I
would just start to get really
aggressive on board so Bishop to c4
you're kind of setting up this Bishop to
f7 attack here and it doesn't really
matter that you've given up this pawn
that's why you're playing a game that
you want to be very very aggressive now
the best move would be Knight to h6
protecting the square right here it is
fairly difficult for someone playing
this Ponta
five to find that the night to h6 and
besides just defending the square it's
not doing too much on board and so I
would play pawn to d3 and this this kind
of allows for them to take material and
you just continue to get more pieces
involved so if they take right here I
would go ahead and castle on the
kingside you don't mind if they continue
to take material because you're just
looking for them to clear up the board
and just have more piece involvement
attacks that they take here you take
back with your queen right here you have
your queen attacking this pawn
you have your Bishop attacking the
square right here you can easily get
your rook involved rook over here to e 2
or e 1 you can get your dark square
bishop so you have a lot of attacks on
this board all in all I think it's a
pretty fun way to play this opening that
they don't play Knight to h6 let's say
they play pawn to e6 definitely not the
best way for black to respond about
would continue pawn to d3 and then if
they take here you could castle on the
King side same kind of thing they don't
have to take let's say they played
Knight to c6
I still castle on the King side you
don't want to just take here on e4 and
then have them come down exchange Queens
off the board you lose a lot of your
threats if you give up the Queen
theoretically if you run it through a
chess engine it might say you know yeah
it's fine give up the Queen's but that's
not why you're playing the Tennyson game
you want more active pieces very strong
pieces on board so definitely make sure
you're casting on the King side you want
them to be taking with their pawn and
from there deciding how you want to
continue now they could instead of pawn
to e6 let's say they want to get their
Queen involved so Queen down here to d4
I want to attack the bishop here I want
to you know start to try to attack some
other squares on the board
okay don't any more about that recognize
that you still have that threat on f7
you're always going to be looking at
that any time you have your Bishop here
on c4 you're always going to be looking
for an opportunity to come here to f7 so
then King here to d8 and then pawn to
d three and this is a great position for
whites you have some very active pieces
the King on D eighth is not going to be
able to castle so all in all very good
position from white now instead of
defending with their pawn they may
decide to go and get pretty aggressive
and play Queen to d5 protecting it with
their Queen play pawn to d3 we've kind
of seen this move before if they decide
to take you could play Knight here to c3
or you could play Bishop takes here on
d3 I really like Bishop takes on d3
because it does give them an opportunity
to make a mistake of queen down here to
g2 if they play Queen to g2 then Bishop
to e4 and the Queen is going to fall the
queen is traps you can no longer get out
of this on so that's why I like playing
that Bishop here to to d3 it also has a
discovered attack depending on where the
Queen may move to this you've up here to
b7 and then the Queen could potentially
fall depending on where it is or how the
board is progressing if we come back a
little bit and say let's you would take
your on d3 the Queen doesn't take on g2
because that would be a mistake if they
played Knight to f6 I would just cast on
the King side continue with our
development if they were to play Queen
to e5 that's fine Bishop here to e3 you
have both your bishops here you can cast
on the King side if you want to all in
all I think this is going to be a pretty
good position from white now coming back
here they don't have to take the pawn
here on d3 they could decide to play
nice to f6 adding more defenders on the
square in the center of the board I
would just go ahead and play nice to see
3 this is going to just kind of gain a
tempo on the board you're trying to when
you give up that step pawn and material
for gambit you're trying to get
something in return
usually a strong attack Knight to c3
does a few things have wanted to tax the
square here on a4 but it does kick this
Queen back that's currently on d5 so
after c3 you could see Queen to d8 and
then I would just go ahead and take with
the knife on e4 you're going to have
this material he's not really going to
take I think if you take that's probably
bad just because now you've controlled
the center of the board he doesn't have
anything on board right now as far as
development so I think this is going to
be a pretty good position from white
next one look at is Bishop here to f5
and this is one the first times where
you'll see me play Knight to c3
now some commentary might say pawn to g4
I think this is a fairly bad move
I don't like blowing up my Kings side I
like playing pretty aggressive with a
gambit but I don't think you have to
play pawn to g4 I would just play Knight
to c3 I think it does exactly what
you're trying to do be pretty aggressive
control the center of the board with
your Knights right now and just let them
know that you can keep adding defenders
to this pawn but eventually it is going
to fall or you're just going to be put
in a really bad position after you
played nice to see three you might see
nice to f6 simple development move and
then continue pawn to b3
if they take here this is one of the
first times where I change it up I play
Queen to f3 and this is where it gets
tricky because once this LightSquared
Bishop is out the Queen yar and f3 can
start to attack this undefended square
here on b7 so if they play pawn here to
e6 then you're taking here on b7 if they
come back and let's say they don't take
with their pawn on d3 let's say they
instead play Knight to c6 okay you can
just go ahead and take here on e4 and
then if they want to exchange on board
that's fine you know eventually they
could exchange if they want to that's
just par for the course that's going to
happen all in all I still doing this is
pretty good it's not nearly as bad to
lose the right to castle once the
Queen's are off the board because at
that particular time you're going to be
getting your keen King in the center of
the board and you have a double Bishop
pair you can easily keep the board
fairly open so all in all I think this
is going to be pretty good so we'll come
back to the beginning when we played the
nights to see three at the beginning
instead of Knight to f6 they could play
Knight to c6 I would play Bishop to c4 I
always like to get the Bishop over here
to c4 in this position when you have the
knight on
g5 it just makes sense you have two
attackers on the square this nice doing
double-duty as far as attacking that the
pawn and upon up here on f7 and so
really depending on what they do if
they're playing Knight to f6 you know
they always have to worry about that
threat Bishop here to f7 it's just
deadly for black so you know they don't
have tons of great options they're going
to be continuing with the same amount of
stuff the Bishop on f5 is really just
playing defense if they would play pawn
to e6 you can go and castle you can play
pawn to e3 which we've seen before get
the dark square Bishop vault into the
game so right now that they're not
really getting their board state where
they should instead they're just
somewhat playing a defense so if their
knight doesn't come to c6 maybe they
play queen down here to d4 adding more
defenders on the square right here I
would continue pawn here to d3 and then
just see what they play next what you
could see is nice to f6 and when I
played this quite often I see nice to f6
more than any of the move because it
makes a lot of sense from anyone that's
not too familiar from black 5 and the
tennyson game that they play development
move controls the turn of the board and
this pawn right here on e4 there's two
ways for white to attack it I usually
have to recommend is Bishop here to see
for attacking the pawn you're on a 7 but
after six there's just not a lot of good
continuation that I think on board and
this Bishop here on on c4 doesn't have a
strong attack for the rest of game
depending on how your opponent plays
instead I like to continue with Knight
to c3 adding more attackers right away
on this pawn here on e4 they could
continue Bishop f5 adding another
defender right here and then you're
going to be playing that pawn to d3 if
they take here that's where we get back
into that Queen to f3
anytime you see the light square bishop
come out you're going to be looking for
that Queen here to f3 you also have the
option of taking with your bishop here
but I like to go ahead and bring the
Queen out here to f3 now if they don't
bring the bishop out and says I don't
want that Queen to come out so instead
I'm just going to continue with Knight
to c6 that's fine now you can go ahead
and play Bishop to c4 if you want to
every C pawn to e6 not the best scenario
because I just don't think you have a
strong attack but castle on the King
side and then if you want to continue
with pawn to d3 a little bit later on
you can philosopher's raishin we're
going to look at is the knight coming
here to c6 and I see two sometimes
employers I feel like they just don't
know what to do with this pawn so they
say I'm not even going to try to defend
it I'm gonna go ahead and continue to do
my thing on the Queen side of the board
i'ma let you recapture and then I will
kind of go from there I don't actually
like to recapture knowing that why it's
going to give this material back I want
to give them more opportunities to try
to hold on to it so I'm gonna play
Knight to c3 hoping that they say okay
you're going to attack these with your
Knights okay I'm going to go ahead and
play pawn to f5 try to hold on to this
so hey that that's fantastic that's what
I want now I can play my Bishop to c4
lots of pressure over here on the King
side and we've kind of looked at before
if the pawns here on f5 you just have
lots of strong attacks and castle on the
Kings side then you can play your pawn
here to d3 and they just kind of have a
weak King side defense over here now
instead if they don't play this pawn to
f5 they could just continue their pawn
to e5 saying yeah I've already given up
on that pawn not even thinking about it
that's where you get into your pawn here
to d3
and then if they take say I'll just go
ahead and get material back as much as
possible because I thought that palm was
already gone you can play Bishop here to
d3 and you have three minor pieces
involved into the game this dark square
Bishop is protecting this knight right
here you can cast on the King side and
start up a lot of pressure on your
opponent so that's some of the lines you
could see in the Tennyson gambit what I
like about it is it's very common for
you to actually play this you don't
require a lot of moves for your opponent
people will play that pawn to e4 and
their opponents come back with pawn here
to d5 you can immediately just play
Knight to f3 and get into that opening
so try this out let me know what you
guys think clearly if black plays
correctly they're going to have a very
strong game but white has so many ways
to attack that I think they're going to
have a pretty good game if their
opponent's not familiar with it so
everyone thanks for watching another
video on a fun gambit and I'll see you
guys in the next video